joining me today is the founding editor
of Colette Claire Lehmann welcome to the
Reuben report thanks Dave thanks for
having me I am thrilled to finally have
you here this has been like what 87
years in the making yeah well I leave a
very long way away so it's difficult for
me to get here yeah well you made it you
made it thousands of miles you are part
of what I would say is IDW Australia
yeah the diaspora yeah exactly
okay so there's a ton I want to talk to
you bout obviously I want to focus on
Colette and the work that you're doing
and we obviously have a lot in common on
the issues that we care about and things
of that nature but first off you are
from Australia I've only had I think two
other guests that are Australian natives
on the show yeah what's going on in
Australia these days what does the rest
of the world need to know about
Australia I would say that in Australia
we're pretty chilled out at the moment
at least politically and culturally
compared to America and even Europe to a
large extent we have a we've had 25
years or more of economic growth so
people are pretty relaxed people are
doing well the middle class is doing
well there's not so much of a feeling
that there's a zero-sum competition
going on like people are fighting over
scarce resources and you know we
obviously have political correctness and
identity politics a lot of that's being
imported from America yeah how does that
get imported because I was mentioning to
you right before we started that a
disproportionate amount of our patrons
the people who support this show are
Australia even if things are going
pretty well there's definitely a segment
of people that are going something's
either not right or we're seeing the
science
yeah it's true I mean it's difficult to
identify exactly how these cultural
trends get imported but for example
through universities through social
media through traditional media so
similar narratives get picked up by
journalists like the oppression
narratives and and we're seeing with the
with the young younger generations how
their
how they pick up ideology through social
media and through the echo chambers and
the filter bubbles that are so easily
accessible yeah yeah do you think that
there's a geographic reason that some of
this stuff hasn't fully hit Australia
I mean being surrounded by water yeah
far off place from the rest of us
there's probably a little bit of safety
in that I would imagine well although
borders are changing just because of
Technology yeah it's um yes so we're
more isolated that's for sure we're
smaller so we don't have the same we're
not as diverse as other places like
Europe and the United States we have
less income inequality in Australia
which makes a difference and where we're
actually kind of parochial as well I
mean we do pick up cultural trends from
America but at the same time we just
focus on cooking shows and reality TV
football games yeah yeah so when the
article came out back in was it may or
so the the renegades of the intellectual
dark web you you were included in there
and many of us had not even met you yeah
this is actually our first time being a
person yeah even though we've been
chatting online for a while
were you shocked about the reaction to
that article because it really did sort
of level up all of the issues that we've
been all talking about no I wasn't
shocked at all I think that the general
movement this ideas movement and this
pushback of the the sort of moral
orthodoxy that the politically correct
left have at the moment it's been
brewing for some time and someone just
had to put a label on it someone just
had to name it and I wasn't shocked by
the groundswell of reaction to it
because I've been seeing it through my
work with collect there are just so many
people who write to me every day who say
I love what you're doing I can't write a
blog myself a can't put my name on it
because I would get in trouble at work
or in my university but there are so
many P
or who want to participate in these
discussions but can't for whatever
reason and you know they like to be now
be able to put a label on this general
movement yeah so tell me a little bit
about your personal background what led
you to be one of the people that is okay
putting your name on this stuff because
I do think that's one of the huge issues
here yeah we get all the support from
academics even people in politics and
and regular folks who are like yeah I'm
with you and I see the dangers but I
don't want to put my name on in this so
how did claire lehman end up here
willing to put your name and face to all
this stuff you know i i think i have a
bit more of a risk-taking streak in my
nature and i don't feel the same fear
around social disapproval as a lot of
other people so i was a psychology
graduate student and I left my grad
program and before I left I sort of took
a few risks during during my program and
was sort of hung out to dry by the
university so to speak yeah you want to
give me an example of one of those you
sort of lit up when you said it well I I
complained about the amount of unpaid
work that psychology students had to do
in a clinic that was associated with the
university and they weren't happy with
that and I sort of received a bit of
retaliation for sort of almost
whistleblowing on the amount of
exploitation this clinic wasn't involved
in so I I've always said the first time
I took a risk I've always taken risks
when I've have felt that my conscience
demands that I I do so and what led me
to you create Collette was when I was a
graduate student I was involved in a lot
of online discussions with academics in
psychology and we had such fascinating
interesting discussions that were
completely unlike anything that you
would see in mainstream media and I
thought firstly there's a business
opportunity here if I can bring some of
these
conversations to a market and secondly
you know people need to know that there
are there is scientific evidence and
some of these topics and mainstream
journalists and I'm neglecting to inform
readers about some of these issues or
some of some of this evidence yeah so I
want to read the mission statement from
Colette cuz it's it's pretty freaking
perfect Colette is a platform for free
thought we respect ideas even dangerous
ones we also believe that free
expression and the free exchange of
ideas help human societies flourish and
progress quill attains to provide a
platform for this exchange everybody
seems to be afraid of dangerous ideas
right now right I mean that's why this
little crew of people are together for
whatever our differences are yeah I
think that there's a there's been a
conflation between giving a platform or
exploring ideas and endorsing ideas and
they're not the same thing
so I will publish stuff on Colette that
I don't necessarily agree with
politically I don't see the the fact of
publishing and in necessarily as an
endorsement I also am very clear that
I'm going to make mistakes
as an editor Colette
we don't want to make mistakes about
accuracy and if were ever called out for
publishing something that's not
factually correct we will own up to that
mistake but you know we're living in a
time of intense ideological flux and to
work out where we're all going we need
to be able to talk about things freely
and we need to be able to make mistakes
and I think make being able to make
mistakes is a sign of a healthy
environment and it's a sign of you know
it's part of the creative process yeah
so that the the warriors who want to
shut down debate who want to shut down
free speech and argue that giving a
platform for exploring dangerous ideas
is equivalent to endorsing
they're basically saying that you can't
make a mistake and that's that's really
scary because the only way we move
forward is to experiment test new ideas
see see what works and pick the best
ones out of the experimentation process
and move forward that way yeah so I want
to discuss some of the dangerous ideas
yeah or that you're platforming but it's
interesting that you said this thing
about you don't mind making mistakes
because I feel very much the same I will
sit down with all sorts of people I've
done it before people I agree with and
disagree with some people who I really
don't like what they're talking about
but I try to give everybody a fair shake
and what I'm noticing is there's a
tremendous amount of pushback just on
that that's what you're getting to like
the idea that a you can sit down with
someone and separate a human being from
their ideas but also that there's this
sort of secondary thing that I'm
noticing and I think you you get it too
just from the articles you guys put out
which is that if I don't ask the exact
question that someone wants me to ask or
I miss this or I word this this way but
just this this army that doesn't feel
that organic to me is ready to pounce
and I'm really trying to work through
that like I don't spend too much time
thinking about it but it is a conscious
thing like oh there's gonna be this
group of people that no matter what I do
and really what they're trying to do is
chill everybody out so that you'll only
talk about what they're comfortable with
yeah well there are there are people at
the moment who feel that all of the
important questions have been answered
all of the important moral and ethical
dilemmas have an answer and that at this
point in history
everything's been worked out and anyone
who's exploring different ideas or is
doubtful about these moral issues is
evil your party your races yeah yes so I
come I come from a different approach
where like I don't know what's going on
like I I'm trying to work it out with
other people and I want the freedom to
be able to explore in a weird way does
that get you the most hate because I
think I really believe that's where most
people are I think that
why people appreciate what I do here I'm
just being open about my journey and
listening to people and learning yeah
yeah you know and that but that opens
you up from hate from the both sides
it's a lot easier to just stake out a
position and then you only get hate one
way but when you're like I am gonna hear
both sides you know it's why I love
listening to to Sam Harris and George
Henderson to ban you know the biggest
existential questions that there are
it's like yeah it's like if I've
completely settled my mind on this I
don't know I wouldn't be that impressed
yeah my thought process or something
yeah
well you know I don't get a lot of hate
um I certainly have Twitter trolls but
oh wait I sort of don't really notice it
yeah okay yeah that's probably the
simple way to deal with this all right
so let's let's talk about some of those
dangerous ideas what are some dangerous
ideas that have bubbled up from your
writers that you've had to think about
or that you're you're focused on these
days yeah so because my background is in
psychology we tackle issues that come
from the behavioral sciences so we've
looked at sex differences psychological
sex differences between men and women
differences in interests in occupations
so we've published some articles on why
there are fewer women in computer
science for example and we published a
analysis of James d'amours Google memo
written by four different scientists who
have some expertise in that area we've
published on intelligence research what
were some of the results yeah well they
you know they basically said that
something pretty similar that he was in
the ballpark in terms of getting the
science right and his position is valid
in terms of regular scientific debate
there are observable sex differences
between men and women the differences in
interest in occupations is very robust
and reliable so women are overwhelmingly
interested in
occupations which have something to do
with people so caring professions
medicine even law whereas men have more
interest in occupations that are to do
with systems and things so anything
mechanical computer science and there's
no there's no difference between the
average intelligent scores between men
and women and the evidence around
differences in verbal and mathematical
ability is somewhat mixed I mean you can
you can have debates backwards and
forwards over the strengths of those
differences but the difference in
interest is very robust so why are
people so afraid of that why is it that
there is a set of people out there right
now that want us to act to be all equal
in their minds but it actually force us
to go against nature I mean that's what
yeah that's what this really is well
there is a fear that if you acknowledge
that there are differences between
individuals or groups that you're saying
that one group is inferior
so there's being a the idea that we have
to be the same to be equal has been a
very prevalent and strong idea I don't
know who came where the idea comes from
but it's it's it's dangerous because if
you if you argue that no true equality
can be achieved unless we're all the
same then no true then we can't have
equality no however if you argue that no
we are all morally equal and that we
deserve equal opportunity and the equal
we deserve equal opportunities to live a
happy flourishing life however there are
differences between us yeah and you can
preserve that ethical principle so it's
very problematic for people who think
that there can be no equality between
men and women unless we're proven to be
same identical because the evidence
doesn't support this the idea that we're
the same yeah what are what are some of
the other dangerous ideas okay so we've
already we're doing the dangerous role
yeah yeah we've published work on
intelligence research which is
controversial we've published articles
about the her intelligence are you
talking about of intelligence and race
because this seems to be one that people
seem to be all that's yeah that's a
hugely controversial issue and we've
published we published a defense of the
Charles Maurice the bell curve because
after he had his conversation with Sam
Harris Vox came out and wrote a hit
piece or wrote some some kind of article
that misrepresented what they talked
about and the bell curve and so we
published a response from Professor
Richard hire who's the editor of the
intelligence journal so he's a
preeminent expert in this area and he
defended Charles Murray's book and
defended the conversation that they had
and said this is an important issue it's
scientifically valid and has merit to
talk about these issues and they got
they were they got the science right so
we we don't aim to be provocative for
the sake of just being inflammatory
right we we have an objective where we
want to protect the scientists who have
who are doing this work or who are
having these comfort conversations we
want to we want to protect the
individuals who are doing the knowledge
production or the research we want to
protect them from the boxes and the
journalists who just want to write hate
pieces just to get the clicks so we have
a sort of a commitment to those people
who are doing risky work and need that
kind of protection you're going to my
soft spot today because as as we're
taking this on
as we're taping there's only like an
hour ago Vox did a piece about me about
how I'm part of the reactionary right
yeah and it's just like you guys so in a
weird way your your job in some respect
has become sort of like a force field to
just allow people to do the work yeah
that they're supposed to be doing yeah
that's right because universities for
all sorts of different reasons are
neglecting their duty to academic
freedom right and academic freedom is
meant to exist to protect scientists in
particular who are doing work which
contradicts the religious orthodoxy of
the time or the moral orthodoxy and it's
quite clear to me that there are
scientists doing work which challenges
politically correct dogmas and I don't
see universities doing a very good job
at protecting those scientists and so we
feel like we can fill the gap where do
you think the the Gender Studies stuff
fits into all this because in a weird
way it seems like it's all being
whittled down to that somehow that now
especially related to trans issues I was
just talking to a fairly well-known
public professor yesterday off the
record yeah about how he's going into
his old even though he's factually
correct that his calm you know confident
about his research he's going into old
lesson plans to change wording just
because he doesn't want to deal with the
mob so things that were completely
acceptable three four years ago yes now
having to edit out I mean that's that's
truly dangerous so what is going on with
the Gender Studies departments in their
essays ah it's all moving so fast it's
hard to really to analyze what's going
on when it's shifting so fast but
certainly many of the humanities
departments took a turn back in the
1970s and they took they took on these
fashionable theories such as post
structuralism and they they rejected
empirical methods
so when the argument if we were trying
to give them all the credit yeah that
they're due at least in the argument if
you're if you're rejecting empirical
science or herbal facts what is your
argument that leads you there cuz I look
people watch us going that's just no
it's great yeah but they obviously
believe it so let's try to give the
devil his due right yes so post
modernists have a good point and that is
that we are all biased and a scientist
looking at an issue such as sexuality
has his or her own biases right and so
the questions that the scientist asks
when he or he or she is designing a
survey or designing a lab experiment are
going to have some bias embedded within
them but so that's true and the post
modernists had that insight however the
mistake they make is getting rid of a
per Imperial and objective methods all
together and just saying because we're
biased what's the point right so they're
doing like a massive over correction yes
yes yeah when when what should be done
is acknowledging yes we all have our
bias and if I'm a scientist designing a
study I'm going to have my bias and it
might get embedded into the work that
I'm doing however there are ways to
correct that and we want to improve our
quantitative methodologies in order to
correct for our own biases the the
problem that the post modernists have is
that they say well the bias is there so
let's put it all in the bin and we're
just going to double down on the bias
and just talk about lived experience I
mean that it's just taking the
completely the wrong direction right I
mean it's quite literally the reverse of
the scientific yeah so basically they're
they're saying that that bias is truth
right I mean if you're saying bias that
the lived experience is what truth is
then bias is truth you know I don't have
you saw it but I did this this talk at
University of New Hampshire and this
woman was yelling at me this trans woman
calling me all right and all of this
other nonsense shouting me down I didn't
realize this until two months later or
something but it turned out she was a
gender studies professor at school yeah
so you got a gender studies professor
trying to shout
down an invited speaker while live
tweeting that I'm alright or whatever
yeah it's like I'm pretty sure I'm not
right about everything I'll concede you
on that even though I want I said she
should be treated with respect
yeah you know quality and all that but
your bias that you're acting on right
now definitely is not closer to truth
yeah yeah so I the way I think of it is
that you know there is an objective
reality and the way we get to objective
realities through the scientific method
whereas post modernist academics believe
a lot of them believe that reality is
created through language and discourse
and I think that's one of the reasons
why they believe that words can be
violent because if reality is actually
created through language and discourse
and there's some kind of there's some
toxic discourse then they truly believe
that reality can be changed through
words and so I think that's why they get
so upset about freedom of speech and
just having discussions because they
truly believe that words can change the
way the world is constructed right so
for now they say it's okay to punch your
Nazi well they call everybody Nazis then
it's okay to punch a Nazi and then we
can go
you know however far down that road we
want to go and then then you're
completely condoning but how concerned
are you that these ideas are going to
trickle up higher into places of power
and that once they look we know they're
in the media you've already mentioned
Vox and a couple of those other things
but that once they're really in the
places of power in Australia or in the
States or else that the screws are
really going to be turned against us
because yeah I'm for free speech yeah
I'm would be mostly be concerned about
these ideas getting into the law
traditionally the law is a conservative
field and they are pretty good at
resisting political fads but you can see
with the way that law is taught in law
schools at the moment that there is
critical legal studies and often
critical legal studies is a
mandatory component so they teach like
the feminist interpretation of law and
these approaches can undermine some of
the basic fundamentals or foundations of
how the law is meant to work so I yeah I
am worried that there are a lot of
attacks on Drupal due process at the
moment freedom of speech and the
scientific method those three things are
foundations of a civilized society and
all of them are being attacked at the
moment yeah how does me to fit into this
because you've been somewhat critical of
that I think it's all three of those out
there look you know obviously me too
started as a really legitimate and
powerful movement in identifying the the
predation that Harvey Weinstein was
engaged in and and surely there are
there have been many powerful men in the
last couple of decades working in
industries where there's a lot of young
women around and they have positions of
power and they're able to exploit those
positions but you know I'm a young woman
myself right and I I don't see sexual
harassment as being as pervasive as a
lot of people claim and I also think
it's very dangerous to make accusations
against people publicly because our
reputations are so valuable and so
important that you know we need to
respect other people's ability to have
have their their reputation and making
accusations in public sort of goes
against my my feeling that it feels
vindictive to me and it feels dangerous
a dangerous path to go down because for
every true accusation their years of
sexual harassment there's going to be
someone who is you know there's there
are going to be people who have
conflicts
and then the conflict someone feels like
they can resolve a conflict through
making an accusation of sexual
harassment and that's really scary we
don't we don't want people to resolve
their conflicts by making public
accusations right but I definitely think
there's a certain set of people that
don't mind collateral damage right I
mean that seems to be what's happening
right now and people you see this public
people that are tweeting these kind of
things like it doesn't matter if it is
taking down a couple innocent people
that's how dangerous this thing is that
strikes me as far more dangerous and I'm
not belittling any of the actual yeah
things that some of these women have
gone through yeah it's scary it's the
desire for collective punishment and
that collective punishment is is scary
it if you look at the Geneva Convention
that was established after World War two
the UN declared collective punishment a
war crime so the idea is that when there
is a conflict between ethnic groups in
certain places if if one if some people
are killed in that inner conflict you
can't then go and wipe out a village as
a collection collective rich retribution
because that's how these war crimes
happen so now we're this like you said
this collateral damage this desire for
collateral damage is being normalized
like people don't seem to understand how
dangerous this is and how unjust it is
but it is part of the issue that perhaps
they do understand it but they so want
to destroy the system this is you know
I'm I've been on tour with Jordan
Peterson one of the things he's been
talking about a lot lately is yes you
can acknowledge that we don't have
perfect systems and perfect systems are
probably impossible to ever get to but
now we have this new thing in the system
which is let's just freakin destroy the
whole thing to build our perfect system
yeah I I think people don't understand
because we're not taught anymore we're
not taught history properly we're not we
don't learn about human nature in school
and how it's almost an instinct to want
to desire retribution
tribution and vindictive justice I think
it's it's part of our natures to want to
punish people and punish groups and our
institutions like due process and the
presumption of innocence they sort of
they go against our instincts but that's
why they're super weak yeah yeah yeah
and I think what we're seeing is just
sort of like a regression back to our
more tribal instinctive nature and
because our education system is so
atrophied young people aren't being
taught the value and the fragility of
these institutions how they came about
why they're so important why we must
protect them so that I think there's
just a basic ignorant about why these
institutions institutions exist in the
first place and then we're regressing
back to our more primitive natures yeah
how do you think social media fits into
this because I did a video I think it's
almost three years ago now that online
culture is becoming mainstream culture
and I think that that's what we're
seeing now what used to be just
relegated to the mean makers and the
Peppe people has now just leaked
everywhere and just everyone in public
is acting sort of as their worst selves
all the time yeah it's all of this let's
either destroy the system or let's
ignore legitimate problems well when you
don't have proper law and order you do
get mob justice and vigilante justice in
real life and you can see that
throughout history you've got you get
lynchings you get pogroms you get groups
like mobs of people going and attacking
an individual who they think he's guilty
of like a sex crime or some other crime
and killing the person so and then what
happened was as we developed legal and
social norms that stopped that kind of
vigilante justice from taking place and
if you are a vigilante you can just you
can get in trouble with the law and then
we've developed social norms that
prevent people from just forming mobs
and going attacking people in the street
but social media is this new technology
and we don't haven't developed any of
the legal or social norms the
and so it's brought back this mobbing
behavior which is part of our nature
it's brought it back but we haven't yet
developed any of the norms to sort of
suppress it or mitigate against it yeah
and I think we eventually will develop
these norms but it's going to take a
while and there's going to be a fitness
that people sort of metaphorically
lynched in the process yes so that's
actually an interesting segue to
something that's been on my mind lately
so you know Alex Jones got booted from
Twitter and YouTube and Facebook or
whatever I don't even want to talk about
any of the things that he talks about it
does not matter hmm but but these tech
companies basically decided that this
one guy is too dangerous you know
Farrakhan can be on here and a mom yeah
never you whoever else you want to pick
that you don't like and be on here but
this guy you know even PayPal took him
out last week do you think that the free
speech crew for getting his ideas do you
think we should have offered a better
defense of why this person but person
should be allowed to use these things I
mean should the guy be allowed to make a
phone call should he'll out should he be
like I've running water at his house
where do we draw the lines for this yeah
well I think these tools that we use
such as payment processing and social
media such as Twitter the instant
messaging that the tools and they should
be treated as as such like having
electricity or water and so you believe
they're a public good basically the same
yeah what getting water to your house
getting the fall in line connected to
your house yeah and and they shouldn't
be politicized and as soon as you
politicize these tools then it's there's
a slippery slope and you know then
there's going to be arguments about who
do we ban next what standards do we want
to set and that kind of thing in in the
context of Alex Jones I think there's
probably more to the story that the
public is aware of so I don't want to
comment on him specifically but and I
don't want to make it it's just the
general idea that a digital
assassination can occur because we're
all agreeing to terms of services that
yeah I'm not sitting around with a
lawyer every time I click
except to the news yeah service yeah and
that eventually you could move on
anybody you know Anna we know the way
these ideas work you don't get one
person and then suddenly be like oh well
we're good to go
it's like who do you get next yeah and
the payment processing is is scary I
mean the idea that that should be
politicized is just that is crazy
yeah so what do you think the solution
is I mean I think you probably know my
solution is that we need more
competition what I'm really
understanding a big counter to that
because where is the county where is it
yeah no look I don't have the answer and
I tend towards being economically
liberal however some of these tools as
you said our public goods and perhaps
need to be thought of as public words
rather than rather than private and you
know I'm not I'm open to ideas of
regulation government intervention and
I'm also open to ideas about breaking up
some of the monopolies because we
competition would be lovely but it's a
bit difficult at the moment because some
of these companies have got monopolies
in lots of different verticals so Google
for example has the search engine
monopoly they've got that almost got the
advertising monopoly so they're
leveraging their monopoly in one area
into others and that that just shuts
down competition yeah do you think it's
even something a little more perverse
than that which is that you know look
there's obviously I'm not over the lid
on anything here there's obviously tons
of discussions with all sorts of people
about how do we compete with YouTube or
how do we compete with any of these
things yeah but I think partly what's
happening it's not just people are going
there this this big monolith other
people are actually genuinely afraid of
what it means to go up against them it's
not like it's gonna just be a hard work
situation it's like what does it
actually mean to go up against the
world's information leader
well you can't compete against the
monopoly that's the definition of a
monopoly there's no competition and and
these some of these companies Napoles
and they have captured the market so
effectively that
you cannot compete with them and so we
either have to think about regulating
them so that they're free and open to
everybody or breaking up their ability
to control the market I mean yeah yeah
this is the tough part for the
libertarian part of me is like oh no I
do it yet I do sense I'm being pinged
into yeah that that kind answer
[Music]